My name is Dianne Katione and I'm here with Author Kind recording for digital lives. Hi Author,
Tell me a little bit about yourself. (Author: I am
. I. Don't want no common. Life.
One.
Symptom and someone will walk. Up. (Dianne:And do
you live at home. (Author: No I'm in a group home. (Dianne: Which group home do you live in?
.
(Author: The ton of flight group home next to the train station.
(Dianne: So tell me what makes you different from other individuals Author
(Author: When I went to high school
Finding to... someone...would let...that
?Inaudible?
To come and talk. Help me with the walk
which makes it diff - me different  - from everyone else. So you needed
Assistance? No. Do you consider your life
Difficult? Sometimes it's difficult
and sometimes not. What makes life difficult for you?
I can't ? chew? everything and people
that are not disabled ?with gym?
Can you tell me if there is anyone that is the most important person in your
life? Who is the most important person in your life?
My mother.
What is the most important lesson you've learned from your mom?
That we keep on trying.
They think they can't do
something and maybe they'll be able to do it.
I have a favorite quote and that
quote is "The only person you are destined to become is the person you decide to
be." Tell me what person you decided to be, Arthur.
A
librarian. You want to be a librarian? Yeah. I work for a library.
Do you want to work for a public library? Which one? I work for the Huguenot library
New York Public Library. That's who's doing this project.
Do you want to become a librarian? I am. I work at the
?Macomb's Bridge Library? Oh, that is incredible. Very good.
Can you finish this sentence for me? I draw my strength from...
.
What makes you strong?
What... what are some of the things when you wake up in the morning do you
feel. Strong? Do you feel sad? Do you feel like
have courage? I feel like I have courage. And what makes you feel
like you have courage? What are some of the things that make me feel like I feel so courageous
today. Is it anything in particular that makes you feel that way?
Just my mother
and my ?family? trying to get me to come to school
to get my education.
Is there something you would like people to know about individuals
like yourself, Arthur, that battle with a disability every day?
It's not fun
to deal with it and make me take medication and stuff.
Well, I want to thank you so much for this interview.
Thank you for sharing your story with me. Good luck in your library career. We have something in
common. Thank you so much. We'll be -- You're welcome.Thank you very much.
Much.